pulling music for tolerable David I
wanted to give the audience a taste of
what it would have been like in 1921 to
have been at a screening of tolerable
David the music is all drawn from music
that would have been widely available
stock music for Senate movies and put
together like local pianos your movie
house would have done of course in a
bigger city you'd have an orchestra but
pretending we're in a smaller town with
just the piano favorite part of
tolerable David I noticed the the
mothers or the women brushing away flies
from over the dinner table with some
shredded up newspaper on a stick
something that that it it helps connect
us as an audience member into the heat
and you don't you can't really show the
flies on screen but you think about that
and and and just sort of the general
everyday grime and it makes the people
very real and human and the food fresh
and and they all they come out of the
screen and and become real
and never weekend I because I also play
the harp so I have to say it's a moment
with a harpist on screen so it's it
always catches my eye but what's so
wonderful is it's a wonderful
bait-and-switch that harold lloyd is set
up because you're looking at the harp
and and you're totally distracted by it
and then there's a wonderful gag which
you'll have to watch the film together
it's a wonderful setup and I had a
wonderful bait and switch and I think
the audience did not be curious to see
how they how they respond to it but it's
a it's a wonderful musical gag - which
is great because it's a silent movie but
it's a music gag so you couldn't ask for
more
you